aujourd'hui l'IRSN comme la SN sont deux
entités qui sont reconnus au niveau
international et notre reconnaissance
elle est essentiellement fondée par le
poids de la du parc nucléaire en France
c'est clair que lorsque l'on discute
avec nos homologues américains ou
japonais le fait que l'on nous ayons 56
réacteurs en exploitation que nous ayons
de la désinstallations sur la totalité
du cycle du combustible que l'on a une
politique de gestion des déchets qui
soient exemplaires et reconnus au niveau
international fait que nous avons une
influence nous sommes écoutés parce que
nous avons nous sommes adossés à une
expérience nucléaire de longue date qui
est de très haut niveau mais nous avons
en fait une action qui est qui est
dispersé puisque il y a d'un côté la SN
qui a ses relations avec les homologues
à l'étranger et de l'autre côté
l'irsl qui a aussi des relations avec
nos propres homologues parce que nos
homologues ils ont l'expertise et la
décision qui est intégrée eux ils ont
tout nous on est séparés et trop on a un
contact l'un et l'autre avec les mêmes
personnes ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
donc je pense qu'on renforcera également
la notre influence et la manière dont
nous pourrons avoir les relations avec
nos plus grands homologues étrangers
dans une période cruciale pourquoi il
est crucial il y a aujourd'hui entre 30
et 40 pays dans le monde qui envisagent
qui ne sont pas nucléarisés et qui
envisagent de s'ouvrir au nucléaire pour
pouvoir répondre bien sûr à l'urgence
climatique ces pays ont besoin
d'assistance ils n'ont pas
d'infrastructures de contrôle de la
sûreté ni d'expertise pouvoir
accompagner éventuellement la conquête
par l'industrie française on est là on
n'est pas là pour pour développer
l'industrie mais accompagner des
mouvements de l'industrie française à
l'étranger pour dire à nos homologues
nous nous sommes en situation de pouvoir
vous apporter un appui dans le
développement de votre infrastructure de
contrôle et expertise ça me semble
plutôt
un gage d'efficacité et